bonjour à toutes et à tous je vous
présente et piquionne et python gars de
la famille des brachycéphales idée c'est
minuscule grenouille sont brésiliennes
orange est toxique et comme si elle
débarquer des années 80 elle adore
porter du fluo cette histoire de
grenoble fluo commence par une étude sur
le son une équipe de recherche
internationale menée par une bio acousti
sienne et spécialiste de l'évolution
s'est intéressé aux champs de celle que
l'on surnomme les grenouilles citrouille
durant la saison des amours
on peut les apercevoir deux jours à la
recherche d'un partenaire et si on tend
l'oreille on peut entendre ce sont et
non il ne s'agit pas du son d'un clic et
mais bien du chant des grenouilles
citrouilles en étudiant la structure de
l'oreille des fip yom et pitt en gare
l'équipe de recherche a découvert
qu'elles sont sourdes à leurs propres
champs quoi pourtant ça demande un sacré
effort de produits rançon sans compter
que ça attire les prédateurs et d'un
point de vue évolution ça pose pas mal
de questions à quoi
[Musique]
bien décidé à comprendre comment ces
mini grenouille communiquent entre elles
et découvrir leurs techniques de drague
les scientifiques sont partis à la
recherche de signaux visuels qu'elle
pourrait utiliser
qu'est ce que tu espères oui parce qu'il
se trouve que ces espèces sont justement
connu pour utiliser des signes et des
mouvements de bouche en période de
reproduction
un genre de langue des signes de
grenouilles à u2 est à la recherche de
motifs sur la peau des grenouilles
la scientifique et ses collègues du
muséum d'histoire naturelle les août
éclairé avec une lampe uv et la wka les
grenouilles se sont illuminés
[Musique]
face à un tel mystère de l'évolution la
bio akossi sienne a alors réuni autour
d'elle une équipe pluridisciplinaire et
internationale pour étudier cette
fluorescence d'un côté et des experts de
la reconstruction et de l'imagerie des
eaux
de l'autre des physiciens des
spécialistes de l'imagerie pour l'étude
des matériaux anciens mais aussi des
biologistes des chimistes et des
paléontologues
car ce que vous voyez sur ces images ça
n'est pas la fluorescence provenant de
la peau mais celles générées par les
eaux des grenouilles qui absorbe les
ultraviolets et émettent une lumière que
l'on voit à travers la peau une telle
intensité de fluorescence des eaux n'a
été observée chez aucun autre animal
jusqu'à présent en utilisant des
techniques d'imagerie développé pour
l'étude des matériaux anciens
les chercheurs ont comparé la
fluorescence de différentes kornoi ici
et fip yom pitt en ga et leur cousine
sous lumière naturelle
puis sous une lampe uv en ne
sélectionnant que la lumière issue de la
fluorescence
les chercheurs ont montré que les motifs
qui apparaissent sont en fait créé par
des tissus osseux inhabituel le
squelette tout entier et fluorescent
mais au niveau du crâne et du dos les
grenouilles citrouille possède ce que
l'on appelle des plaques osseuses
en fait c'est la peau elle même qui
sauce if i 6o syfy c'est la peau elle
même qui devient de l'os et c'est ce qui
fait apparaître les motifs
il réunit des scientifiques étudient
actuellement les origines du phénomène
est ce une molécule particulières qui
seraient présentes dans les eaux ou est
ce la structure de l'os lui même mais
surtout il reste une question que l'on
se pose tous à quoi ça sert rien ne dit
que cette fluorescence est une fonction
elle pourrait peut-être permettre aux
grenouilles de mieux repérer leurs
partenaires sauf que le phénomène est
spectaculaire quand on observe pitt en
ga dans le noir éclairé par une lampe uv
mais de jour la quantité d'uv est
beaucoup plus faible et la fluorescence
et masqués par la lumière ambiante
des travaux complémentaires sur le
comportement des grenouilles et leurs
capacités visuelles permettront d'y voir
plus clair
certains oiseaux et araignées ont la
capacité de voir des motifs fluorescents
même illuminé par la lumière du jour des
prédateurs en quête d'un petit snack
pourrait ainsi être alertés sur la
toxicité de ces grenouilles orange pour
résumer nous avons deux minuscule
grenouille toxiques qui sont sourds à
leurs propres champs qui communiquent en
langue des signes qui ont des auffes lui
au récent et une peau super fine et
orange
donc si comme moi vous pensez qu'on a
trouvé le premier x-men qui est une x
grenouille n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo commentée et mai et puis
fiba je suis désolé j'ai pas trouvé tut
d eau d eau fluo idéaux fluo et surtout
n'oublie pas de ta bonne et qui ceci
fille qui ceux qui se sont
syfy